Darrin Metcalf Nick the hi Darrin
hiya you promise on student loans is
destroyed your reputation why would we
ever believe anything else you say nice
easy way to start look firstly got it
wrong I said sorry musically no less I
when you make a mistake in politics just
as in life in politics just as in life
sometimes you can't do exactly what you
want
I was absolutely between a rock and a
hard place five years ago on that
particular policy second year out you
can you can at least give me credit for
the many many other things that I have
actually put into practice whether it's
taking lots of people on low pay out of
paying any income tax the biggest
expansion of apprenticeships this
country has ever seen the biggest reform
of our pension system in a generation
more money into local into schools to
help with the education of disadvantaged
children more childcare shared parental
leave healthy lunches for little kids at
primary school the list goes on look I I
except for this some people and you may
you may be one of them for whom that one
thing you can't forgive you can't forget
why did vote for it and not just abstain
because it was such a key thing you had
all your candidates going around with
these things why didn't you abstain when
it came to the vote because all those in
favor that's the thing that upset people
well I mean what happened as you may
remember was the previous government the
Labour government introduced fees and
then increase them when we came into
government there's no money left David
Cameron has been waving around the
letter which provided to the Liberal
Democrat chief secretary of the Treasury
at the time saying there was no money
left and both the larger parties as they
I think would admit if they if you'd
asked them about it wanted fees to go up
very very considerably in fact the
report commissioned at a time into all
of this said there should be no upper
limit at all so in a sense what we did
was get the fairest deal we could in
those circumstances and thankfully now
got more young people at university than
ever before but look as I said earlier
my experience is some people absolutely
will say you know we can't forget that I
hope there are plenty of other
fair-minded folk who will accept that
nonetheless there are many many many
other good policies that I did put into
practice right anybody want to come in
on this year's area middle
yes yes you in the center policy of
increasing tuition